can the effects of climate change be
reversed on Tuesday MEP is reaffirmed
the eus commitment to reduce greenhouse
gas emissions and specified in the doha
amendment of the Kyoto Protocol among
the main polluters the EU is one of the
few to set binding targets the author of
the report called an international
community to follow Europe's example
loss photo / grande que la doble mo
farah probablemente EDI shera-khan
venture alcuni pezzi ancora cozy DTM
urge ntt pole at Cena k Sinatra piu
grande meta tirsan più grande me te
taura Achill mente another big polluter
the US declared during the g7 summit in
Germany that I wants to decarbonize the
economy but some are skeptical and we've
seen extremely strong language coming
out of the g7 meeting of this week but
these are words words and words but
other m eps have a rather positive
approach a country like China is also
realizing that they can profit from a
new technology that it is an economic
model to build on a new energy system
and that they also can be a leader in
innovation the next UN climate
conference in Paris will be crucial in
satin binding targets for the reduction
of greenhouse gas emissions